Le premier endroit où j'aimerais vous emmener
est ce que beaucoup considèrent comme l'abîme naturel le plus profond sur Terre.
Et je dis considèrent parce que ce processus est toujours en cours.
Il y a d'importantes expéditions prévues pour l'année prochaine
dont je vous parlerai un peu.
Une des choses qui a changé
pendant les 150 dernières années, depuis que Jules Verne
a eu ses grands concepts de science-fiction sur ce qu'était le monde souterrain
est que la technologie nous a permis d'aller dans ces endroits
qui nous étaient auparavant complètement inconnus, et n'étaient que spéculations.
On peut maintenant descendre des milliers de mètres sous Terre dans une relative impunité.
En chemin, nous avons découvert des abysses fantastiques et des chambres tellement grandes
qu'on peut voir sur des centaines de mètres
sans que la ligne de vue ne soit brisée.
Lorsqu'on part pour quelquechose comme cela, on peut généralement être sur le terrain
n'importe où depuis deux jusqu'à quatre mois,
avec une équipe aussi petite que 20 ou 30 jusqu'à aussi importante que 150.
Et beaucoup de gens me demandent,
Mais quel genre de personnes trouvez-vous pour des projets comme ça ?
Et bien que notre processus de sélection
ne soit pas aussi rigoureux que celui de la NASA, il est néanmoins complet.
Nous recherchons des compétences, de la discipline, de l'endurance et de la force.
Au cas où vous vous le demandiez, ceci est notre test de force !
(Rires)
Mais on apprécie aussi l'esprit de corps
et la capacité à résoudre diplomatiquement les conflits
alors qu'il y a un stress énorme dans ces endroits éloignés de tout.
Nous avons déjà largement dépassé les limites de l'endurance humaine.
Dès l'entrée, rien n'est comparable à une grotte commerciale.
Vous voyez ici Camp Two dans un endroit appelé J2, pas K2, mais bien J2.
Nous sommes ici à peu près à deux jours de l'entrée.
Et c'est un peu comme un voyage d'alpinisme de haute montagne à l'envers,
sauf que maintenant vous descendez au cœur d'une de ces choses.
L'idée est d'essayer de prendre des mesures afin d'améliorer le confort
quand vous êtes en bas, où c'est humide, froid et extrêmement sombre.
Je dois aussi vous dire que tout ce que vous voyez
est éclairé artificiellement avec beaucoup de mal.
Sinon, c'est l'obscurité totale dans ces endroits.
Plus vous aller profond, plus vous entrez en conflit avec l'eau.
Sommairement c'est comme un arbre collectant l'eau qui descend.
Et finalement, vous atteignez des endroits où c'est formidable et dangereux
et malheureusement, les diapos ne leurs rendent pas justice.
Donc, j'ai une courte vidéo prise à la fin des années 1980.
C'est la descente dans le Plateau Huautla au Mexique.
(Vidéo)
Je dois vous dire que les techniques que vous voyez
sont obsolètes et dangereuses.
On ne ferait pas ça aujourd'hui, à moins de le faire pour un film.
(Rires)
Pendant que j'y suis, je dois vous dire que
malgré l'avalanche de films Hollywoodiens sortis l'année dernière,
nous n'avons jamais vu de monstres sous terre...,
du moins ceux qui peuvent vous manger.
S’il y a un monstre souterrain,
c'est le poids psychologique de l'isolement
qui commence à toucher tout le monde
une fois passé la barre des trois jours de l'entrée la plus proche.
L'année prochaine, je mènerais une équipe internationale vers le J2.
Nous allons atteindre les moins 2,600 mètres
-- ça fait un peu plus de 8,600 pieds sous terre--
à 30 km de l'entrée.
L'équipe de tête sera sous terre pendant 30 jours consécutifs.
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait eu une mission semblable depuis longtemps
Finalement, en continuant de descendre,
il y a toutes les chances que vous tombiez sur un endroit comme ça.
Il y a ici un pli dans les couches géologiques
qui se remplit d'eau jusqu'au plafond.
Quand vous aviez l'habitude de trouver ce genre d'endroit
on mettait une note sur la carte qui disait: Siphon Terminal.
Je me rappelle très bien de ce terme pour deux raisons.
La première est que c'est le nom de mon groupe de rock,
la seconde est parce que se retrouver face à ça
m'a obligé à devenir un inventeur.
On a donc commencé à développer
de nombreuse génération de gadgets pour explorer les endroits comme celui-ci.
Ceci est du matériel de survie en cycle fermé
et on peut l'utiliser désormais pour parcourir horizontalement de nombreux kilomètres
sous l'eau et jusqu'à une profondeur de 200m.
Quand vous faites ce genre de chose, c'est comme une SEV
c'est comme une Sortie Extra Véhiculaire dans l'espace,
mais sur une distance plus grande et avec plus de danger.
Cela fait donc réfléchir à comment concevoir votre équipement
pour des longs périples loin d'un point sûr.
Ici, on a un clip de National Geographic
sortit en 1999.
(Vidéo) Narrateur: L'exploration est le processus physique
de poser le pied quelque part où aucun autre humain ne l’a posé avant.
C'est ici que reste le dernier endroit complètement inconnu sur la planète.
En faire l'expérience est un privilège.
Bill Stone: Ça a été filmé aux Chutes Wakulla, en Floride.
Quelques détails à remarquer de cette vidéo: chaque équipement
que vous voyez ici n'existait pas avant 1999.
Ils ont été développés en deux ans et sont utilisés dans tous les projets d'exploration actuellement.
Cet appareil là est appelé le cartographe numérique de parois
et il a fait la première carte 3D jamais créée d'une grotte,
ça c'est passé sous l'eau des Chutes Wakulla.
C'est cet appareil qui a ouvert par hasard la porte
de l'exploration d'un autre monde.
Ceci est Europe.
Carolyn Porco en mentionnait une autre appelé Encélade l'autre jour.
C'est un des endroits où les planétologues
pensent avoir une des plus grande probabilité de détection
de signes de vie extraterrestres dans l'océan qui existe sous la surface.
Pour ceux qui n'ont jamais vu cette histoire,
James Cameron a produit il y a quelques années
un magnifique film IMAX appelé "Aliens Of The Deep"
En voici un bref extrait
(Vidéo) Narrateur: Une mission pour explorer sous les glaces d'Europe
serait le défi ultime pour la robotique.
Europe est si loin que même à la vitesse de la lumière,
cela prendrait plus d'une heure pour qu'une commande arrive jusqu'au véhicule.
Il doit donc être assez intelligent pour éviter les dangers du terrain,
et trouver un site d'atterrissage correct sur la glace.
Ensuite, il doit passer à travers la glace.
On a besoin d'une sonde de fusion.
C'est grosso modo une torpille chauffée par un réacteur nucléaire
Cette glace peut faire entre 4.8 km et 25.7 km d'épaisseur.
Semaine après semaine, la sonde va forer et descendre grâce à son propre poids
à travers cette glace très ancienne, jusqu'au moment...
Maintenant, que fait-on une fois la surface de l'océan atteint ?
On a besoin d'un VSA, Véhicule Sous-marin Autonome.
Ça doit être une petite bête sacrément intelligente, capable de naviguer
et de prendre des décisions seul dans un océan extraterrestre.
BS: Ce que James ne savait pas quand il a sorti ce film
c'est que 6 mois avant, la NASA avait financée une équipe que j'ai créée
pour développer un prototype de VSA pour Europe.
En pratique, je suis passé par 3 ans de réunions d'ingénieurs, de conception
et d'intégration système, et j'ai introduit DEPTHX --
Deep Phreatic Thermal Explorer.
Et comme dit dans le film, c'est une petite bête sacrément intelligente.
Il possède 96 capteurs, 36 ordinateurs embarqués,
100 000 lignes de code de comportement autonome,
emporte l'équivalent de plus de 10kg de TNT en composant électronique.
Voilà sa cible,
la source hydrothermale la plus profonde sur Terre à Cenote Zacaton, dans le nord du Mexique.
Elle a été explorée jusqu'à 292m de profondeur
et en dessous, personne ne sait ce qu'il y a.
C'est une partie de la mission du DEPTHX.
Il y a ici deux objectifs principaux.
Le premier, comment faire de la science en autonomie sous terre ?
Comment transformer un robot en microbiologiste de terrain ?
Il y a plus d'étapes qui rentrent en compte
que j'ai de temps pour vous en parler, mais en gros,
on traverse l'espace, on le remplit de variables environnementales --
sulfure, halogénures, des choses comme ça.
On calcule ensuite les gradients des surfaces, et on emmène le robot à un mur
où il y a de grandes probabilités de vies.
On se déplace le long du mur, dans ce qui est appelé opération de proximité,
cherchant des changements de couleurs.
Si on trouve quelque chose d'intéressant, on le met sous un microscope.
Si ça passe le test du microscope, on passe au prélèvement.
On peut aussi bien prendre des échantillons liquides,
ou bien une carotte solide du mur.
Tout ça sans les mains.
C'est uniquement un comportement autonome
qui est géré par le robot lui-même.
Le vrai tour de force de ce véhicule
est un système complètement nouveau de navigation qu'on a développé,
connu sous le nom de 3D SLAM, pour Simultaneous Localization And Mapping.
DEPTHX est un œil qui voit tout.
Ses capteurs regardent en même temps devant et derrière lui,
permettant de faire de nouvelles explorations
pendant qu'il est toujours en train de produire la géométrie
de ce qu'il vient de traverser.
Ce que je vais vous montrer maintenant
est la première exploration souterraine complètement autonome
jamais réalisée.
En Mai prochain, nous allons descendre à moins 1 000m à Zacaton,
et si nous sommes chanceux, DEPTHX nous ramènera la première
bactérie découverte par un robot.
L'étape suivante est un test en Antarctique, ensuite
si le financement continue et si la NASA a la détermination d'y aller,
on peut potentiellement lancer une mission vers 2016, et vers 2019
on pourrait avoir la première preuve de la vie en dehors de cette planète.
Que dire alors de l'exploration spatiale habitée?
Le gouvernement américain a récemment annoncé son ambition de retourner sur la Lune en 2024.
La réussite de cette mission mènerait
à de rares visites de la Lune par un petit nombre de
scientifiques et pilotes gouvernementaux.
On ne sera donc pas plus avancé qu'il y a 50 ans
à propos de la colonisation de l'espace.
Quelque chose de fondamental doit changer
si nous voulons, de notre vivant, voir l'accès à l'espace devenir commun.
Ce que je vais vous montrer maintenant sont quelques idées controversées.
Et j'espère que vous aller les supporter avec moi et croire
que ce que je vais vous dire est crédible.
Il y a trois fondements pour qu'un privé travaille dans l'espace.
Un d'eux est la nécessité d'un
transport économique entre la Terre et l'espace.
Bert Rutans et Richard Bransons ont
créé ceci dans ce but et je les félicite.
Go, go, go.
La seconde chose dont on a besoin est un endroit où rester en orbite.
Des hôtels orbitaux pour commencer, mais ensuite des ateliers pour le reste d'entre nous.
La pièce finale, le vrai nouveau paradigme, c'est ça:
une station service orbitale.
Ça ne ressemblera pas à ça.
Si ça existait, cela changerait toute la conception future des vaisseaux spatiaux et la planification des missions spatiales
Maintenant, pour vous permettre de comprendre
pourquoi ceci est primordial,
je dois vous donner les bases du cours débutant sur l'Espace.
Le premier point est : tout ce que vous faites dans l'espace vous le payez au kilogramme.
Quelqu'un en a bu une cette semaine ?
Vous la payeriez 10 000 dollars en orbite.
C'est plus que ce que payez pour TED,
si Google lâchait son sponsoring.
(Rires)
Le second est que plus de 90% du poids d'un véhicle est le carburant.
Donc à chaque fois que vous voulez faire quelque chose dans l'espace,
vous brûlez littéralement des quantités d'argent énormes
à chaque fois que vous touchez à l'accélérateur.
Pas même les gars de Tesla ne peuvent combattre cette physique.
Alors, que feriez-vous si vous pouviez avoir votre essence au dixième du prix ?
Il y a un endroit où c'est possible.
En fait, on peut faire mieux -- on peut l'avoir pour 14 fois moins cher
si on trouve du carburant sur la Lune.
Il y a une mission peu connue lancée
par le Pentagone il y a 13 ans, appelé Clémentine.
Et la découverte la plus intéressante de cette mission
est une forte signature d'hydrogène dans le cratère Shackleton
au pôle sud de la Lune.
Ce signal est tellement fort,
qu'il ne peut avoir été produit que par 10 billion de tonnes d'eau
enfouies dans les sédiments, amassées pendant les millions et milliards d'années
d'impacts d'astéroïdes et de comètes.
Si nous voulons obtenir cela, et faire que cette station service soit possible,
nous devons trouver des façons de déplacer de grands volumes de marchandises à travers l'espace.
On ne peut pas le faire pour le moment.
La façon dont sont construits les systèmes actuellement est un empilement de
tubes lancé depuis le sol,
et qui subit une multitude de forces aérodynamiques.
Nous devons dépasser cela.
Et on peut le faire parce que dans l'espace, il n'y a pas d'aérodynamique.
On peut aller en orbite et utiliser des systèmes gonflables pour presque tout.
C'est une idée, à nouveau, qui est sortie de Livermore en 1989,
avec le groupe du Dr. Lowell Wood.
Maintenant, on peut étendre cette idée à pratiquement tout.
Bob Bigelow dispose actuellement d'un appareil de test en orbite.
On peut aller encore beaucoup plus loin.
On peut construire des remorqueurs spatiaux, des plateformes orbitales pour stocker de l'eau et des produits cryogènes.
Encore un autre point.
Quand vous revenez de la Lune,
il faut gérer le mouvement orbital.
En gros, si vous allez 10 000 pieds par seconde plus vite
que vous voulez pour revenir à votre station service,
Vous avez deux choix.
Vous pouvez brûler une fusée de carburant, ou vous pouvez faire quelque chose de vraiment incroyable.
Ou vous pouvez plonger dans la stratosphère,
et dissiper avec précision cette vitesse, et revenir à la pompe à essence.
Cela n'a jamais été fait avant.
C'est risqué et sera un voyage d'enfer --
mieux qu'au parc d'attraction..
L'approche traditionnelle de l'exploration spatiale
est que vous devez emmener assez de carburant
pour ramener tout le monde en cas d'urgence.
Si vous essayez de faire ça pour la Lune,
vous alloez brûler un milliard de dollars rien qu'en carburant en envoyant une équipe là bas.
Mais, si on envoie une équipe de minage là bas,
sans le carburant de retour, au départ --
(Rires)
Aucun d'entre vous n'a entendu l'histoire de Cortez ?
Ce n'est pas comme ça. Je suis plutôt comme Scotty.
J'apprécie ces équipements, et j'estime qu'ils sont vraiment bons
donc on ne va pas les brûler.
Mais, si vous étiez vraiment audacieux,vous pourriez aller là-bas et en fabriquer,
et ce serait la démonstration la plus impressionnante
jamais faite que l'on peut faire quelque chose qui vaille la peine
en dehors de cette planète.
Il y a un mythe qui dit qu'on ne peut rien faire dans l'espace
pour moins d'un billion de dollars et 20 ans.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
En sept ans, on peut monter
une mission industrielle vers Shackleton, et démontrer
que l'on peut donner une réalité commerciale aux voyages en basse orbite terrestre.
Nous vivons un des moments les plus excitants de notre histoire.
Nous sommes à un croisement magique où la demande pour l'accès à l'espace
est poussée en avant par les fortunes privées et l'imagination.
Les stations services orbitales que je viens de vous présenter
pourraient créer une entièrement nouvelle industrie et ainsi fournir
la dernière clef ouvrant l'espace à l'exploration générale.
Pour changer de paradigme, une nouvelle approche complètement différente est nécessaire.
On peut le faire en lançant une expédition industrielle
Lewis et Clark vers le cratère Shackleton,
pour extraire les ressources de la Lune et démontrer
qu'elles peuvent établir la base d'une affaire rentable en orbite.
Parler de l'espace semble toujours être accroché aux ambiguïtés
des objectifs et du calendrier.
Je voudrais conclure maintenant en mettant un piquet dans l'arène à TED.
J'ai l'intention de mener cette expédition.
(Applaudissements)
On peut le faire en 7 ans avec un soutien adéquat.
Ceux qui me rejoindront dans sa concrétisation feront partie de l'histoire
et rejoindront les audacieux du passé qui,
s'ils avaient été là aujourd'hui, auraient vivement approuvé.
Il fut un temps où des personnes faisaient des choses insensées pour élargir les frontières.
Nous avons tous oublié cette leçon.
Maintenant, nous sommes à un moment où l'audace est nécessaire pour avancer.
100 ans après que Sir Ernest Shackleton ait écrit ces mots,
j'ai l'intention de planter le drapeau industriel sur la Lune
et terminer la dernière pièce qui
ouvrira les frontières de l'espace, à notre époque, pour nous tous.
Merci
(Applaudissements)